good morning Facebook it's me Gary and
that's the rock
32 31 31 what number 31 believe Winfield
snow as a kid as a Yankee
typical day and casino comfort room in
Connecticut you know just doing my thing
what I think is most interesting is the
following which is what I've spent my
career on sometimes I've done it well
now I'm really doing it one on one on
one
CRM what I mean by that is in the same
way you think of customers and knowing
everything let's use rec in a positive
way I gotta MIT I gotta make it up free
right if Rick is doing great Rick may
not be motivated by another eight
thousand dollars or 4% he just might not
right he may be motivated by an extra
couple weeks so I'll give you a drink we
have unlimited vacation policy let me
explain did that for first two years
then I created a mandatory three weeks
because a lot of kids especially
youngsters they didn't know how to
handle it so someone didn't use it at
all and then you had some that used it a
lot but here's what's funny we still
have it unlimited I'm thrilled to fire
you for your vacation actions even
though we haven't unlimited yes we have
an unlimited policy that doesn't mean
you should be on vacation 94 days a year
got it
obviously do those five ten-minute
meetings with people when they first
start you've seen that on dailyvee
countlessly but these you know our
breakfast with six different people just
shouldn't [ __ ] you know always trying to
move the needle in making me more
accessible and human and real to even my
own employees as much as I stand and
spew it on this show genuinely wanting a
relationship with them is the actual
answer to this question as much as I
stand in front of them and all hands-on
meetings or send emails it's still tough
to make somebody feel comfortable even
if they've been with me for two three
years and the company to just reach out
and say hey and
about their launched dreams and needs
and so continues she's trying to hack at
creating scenarios you know a breakfast
like this allows something to come up
about a favorite TV show that I then can
mention in the elevator that then leads
to six months from now that person when
are struggling because one other
person's making their life miserable for
them to actually come and speak to me
about it versus finding another job I'm
the least [ __ ] confused person you
will ever meet and I need you to
understand that and the way I solve for
that is to stand in front of you stand
in front of you at scale and say I am
here to have any conversation you need
at any time you know I call it the
Rickey Henderson rule Rickey Henderson
is a baseball player in 1984 that winked
at me as he was going into the dugout
and he became my favorite baseball
player and I supported him and bought
his stuff and bought his baseball cards
you know it's very hard I have six
hundred and change employees right now
you know finding time for everybody is
very very difficult but even the
five-minute meetings though are so sure
they create context it's amazing I've
been sitting with a lot lately and as
I'm catching up and you know whether I
know the town they grew up in order
favorite sports team and what their
ambition is that context becomes
meaningful and
and and it's a it's important and and I
think it has a huge impact on culture
when you go away when you don't become a
faceless CEO or head of this or ahead of
that and you become Gary or Emily or
Ricky it becomes totally different and
and by saying hello for five minutes in
a meeting it leads to them saying hello
to you in the elevator which leads them
saying hello at the holiday party which
leads to them coming to you actually on
an issue its building an actual
relationship what matters the most in my
opinion what I think is absolutely the
future of HR is the one-on-one nature of
it
some people want work-life balance some
want more money some want more
challenges we put everybody this is
school and school doesn't work you can't
put everybody in the same box they're
driven by different things and more
importantly you know this and all of you
know this you're driven by different
things at different points in your life
when you're 22 you might and you didn't
grow up and then you want money when you
crushed it and you're 32 and you found
the man of your dreams and you want to
start a family you're not sure you want
to be a working dad maybe a state like
there's just a million by the way I tell
my employees I take it very in some do I
take it very rogue I tell my employees
I'm like I'm ready for tragedy like
we've had three situations right now
where people are dealing with tragedy
deaths mental illness and like I'm
mentally and my company's prepared for
that you need a four month sabbatical
fine like real stuff and you know like
just real stuff I love my non-billable
overhead it's why we're the
fastest-growing agency ever because we
actually have continuity because we
actually have a team because we actually
have longevity and so I you know you
could try it you know I think this is
entrepreneurial enough for what I can
sense and I don't know and like you have
different things it's a big company but
I think it's I think you should
challenge yourself to come up with one
or two unique HR driven things every
year things they haven't done in the
past but more than anything
doesn't matter what tactic it's not
tactics it's religion if you actually
give a crap about every person here one
by one you will win
got it
what's up snapchat sorry I've been that
my I just wanna [ __ ] business
just headed back to O'Hare now come in
pen stay three flights do you rock not a
bad day gum one nozzle comes through
that was a lot of fun leaving something
car literally the only time I had to
take both my kids to school on the same
day kid no that would have been amazing
no but the only time the singular I've
taken a lot of them individually by
themselves but that I had to take two
might had to have a quick procedure and
we're in between Andy's right so I went
and did that and my little guy is like
thirty minutes after my daughter and I
get out of the cab to take him to the
coffee shop de likes to like hang out in
30 minutes before school and left his
book bag in the taxi gone forever
I know I texted my wife I'm like this is
such good material I'm like I'm like oh
by the way I do a daily vlog that's what
the rock is doing if you were Karis got
it where okay good oh you know what you
know what's good D Rock I say that's the
first time I just realized eventually
enough people know about it that I don't
have to say it every time ah car da an
iconic brand always flattered today when
uh non when big brands of non clients
are asking me to come in and bring value
and and so that's what I do for a living
because really I'm a Salesman when I go
and talk to all these brands that love
to be commercials and catalogs I don't
care about awards I don't give a crap
about the South of France and winning an
award I care about selling crap right
and this sells crap know what extremely
well I really enjoyed that great crew of
a retailer and salesman at heart so
those are always 'extra special for me
and Sal
it's Gary big you got to hit me up what
are we hanging out my man
so imagining and now grinding back
luckily the rock wasn't sitting with me
in the flight between New York and
Chicago was actually slept which is a
rarity but really been up for five hours
sleep the last the last two weekends I
haven't been able to catch up on sleep
rest so feel rundown for me which is a
rarity because for 31 episodes in and
everybody just said what truth is by
even saying and I got competitive plus I
got rest and plus I got energized
there's something to crush this fly from
Chicago to Dallas but uh you know uh
just grinding right like just you know
listen I have no problem with anybody
jumping off this series because I
promise you if you're smart you're gonna
find the layers and things underneath
but like if you're only one chest move
missing me quite basic work and hard
binding making stuff happens it's what
it is I mean it's crazy you think you
might be getting sucked and exhausted
about oh sorry I'm right on the sound
feel it you're at nice oh did I get
there Mike no yeah anyway um uh I had
like up some people like Garrity like
man this is like intense like already
episodes like you know like even like
people actually coming at it as a zing
like hey show some other stuff or just
not the other thing I'm like 30 episodes
man it's been 30 years I wish daily be
started in May of 1998 there'll be a
library of complete and utter exhaustion
ethical food would be cool right I mean
like thirty thirty months like 30
episodes like three months like this is
forever this has been forever
like this what so many successful people
really like not just mine like an even
successful successful parents successful
like everything like
you know anything special takes a
combination of talent and work ethic and
all these things it's like look you know
I have the audacity to dream big things
and stay calm at the expense of taking a
helicopter to Connecticut and back and
they comment expensive you know flying
to Chicago for an hour and then leaving
a comment expensive landing at 1:30
tonight of it 5:40 a.m. wake-up call
everything has a cost you just have to
make sure that the price you're paying
is what you want to intern
you ready to rock
man
it's great dude just
the comments also line up on the rocket
of singing in the lives
Iraqis wanna set the record straight I'm
sorry I love you so much
and I think the ones I love the most
right mom daddy J so it's funny but I
read that I'm like oh man that must
really starting to love t Rock I want to
have that care and level of relationship
with those individuals and that's what I
always hope and unfortunately they don't
always go that way but uh but that is my
aspiration
okay
thank you
d-roc this is how I like it's how I like
the airport's real [ __ ] quiet real
quiet for the hustlers you run a company
of this size what happens is you can't
get to everything on that day there are
things that I know that are broken today
that I'm doing things to fix but you
won't feel it for three or four months
because that's just the way it is right
that's just the game and so I've been
thinking about what do I say up here
that for the 300 400 of you that I don't
know well enough that you here and you
don't believe is what I think about
everything that's what by the way that's
100% what I'm gonna do after this talk
what was said today and how many people
didn't believe it and how do I make sure
they do eventually right that's what I
do
so there's been things that have
happened in last 18 24 months around a
lot of different categories that made me
feel that way I would argue I would
argue this is maybe now as of this
announcement the next most important
role in this company underneath me and
so it's a big one so as of today
starting on Monday we now have a chief
heart officer and that chief heart
officer is actually here so I think we
should grab our chief heart officer
to create a position that really is me
right like the scalable version of what
I do with you guys one-on-one in those
meetings and to have the autonomy to
make decisions that make no sense on
paper but make a whole lot of sense on
heart we want to build the single
greatest human organization in the
history of time